[Música]
una nueva técnica en biología molecular
ha puesto la evolución en nuestras manos
y va a cambiar el mundo se los aseguro y
de paso también ha puesto los genes de
moda una vez más y para saber más o
menos qué tan de moda están me gustaría
saber quiénes aquí han escuchado hablar
de los genes así sea de ficción en una
película levanten la mano
oh sí sí está de moda
y quienes saben cómo funcionan en
realidad esos genes
ok lo bueno es que dentro de 12 minutos
todos vamos a saber cómo funcionan y
para eso les he traído una analogía muy
sencilla
el genoma es el conjunto de todos los
genes que tiene un individuo yo tengo mi
genoma tú tienes tu genoma y cada ser
vivo tiene un propio genoma y ese genoma
es hagan de cuenta un libro de cocina
uno muy muy muy completo en ese libro
cada gen
cada receta es un gen es decir que los
genes que son simplemente instrucciones
para preparar algo para hacer algo
cierto para diferentes eventos
imaginémonos un grado un matrimonio un
picnic usted prepara diferentes
combinaciones de recetas cierto si usted
va a ser una fiesta elegante y va a
pedir unas frituras con un postre de
tres leches a lo mejor no le combinan
muy bien igual me invita porque me las
como
pero de igual forma un evento biológico
también requiere diferentes
combinaciones de genes
y como todos absolutamente todos los
organismos vivos utilizamos el mismo
sistema de información es decir un
alfabeto de cuatro letras
sí je
que es nuestro adn
la evolución se ha encargado
de optimizar la función de esos genes y
crear organismos diversos a partir de
los simples cambios y reorganización de
esos pocos genes
por ejemplo
si comparamos el tamaño del genoma de
una bacteria una bacteria es una sola
célula es diminuta si comparamos en
promedio las células que tenemos dentro
de nuestro cuerpo con el promedio de una
célula humana sería como lo que yo soy
con respecto a este auditorio son
diminutas y aún así tienen
aproximadamente entre 5000 y 7000 genes
el sig elegans es un gusano muy
utilizado en biología molecular y en
desarrollo
tiene aproximadamente 19 mil genes y
mide un milímetro tiene sus propios
sistemas sistema circulatorio
respiratorio autor es un vídeo milímetro
y tiene 19 mil genes
y los seres humanos que ya sabemos cómo
somos tenemos aproximadamente 26 mil
genes
y probablemente hablando
estructuralmente de genes tal vez muchos
menos o sea que toda nuestra complejidad
no es ni siquiera el doble de la
cantidad de genes que tiene un gusano de
un milímetro
eso qué es eso es una evidencia de que
la evolución ha estado usando esos genes
y re usándolos y generando cambios y
reorganizaciones y cada vez va generando
más diversidad más complejidad pero
nunca podremos decir que hay un
organismo mejor que otro simplemente
somos diferentes
la evolución y la evolución nos ha
traído con estos cambios desde hace
3.500 millones de años y esos cambios
han sido puramente aleatorios
pero será posible que uno pueda
esos cambios
puntualmente y dirigirlos en un
organismo en una especie
justamente una nueva tecnología que se
llama crisis por casas
ha traído un sistema un mecanismo que
nos permite editar el genoma de
cualquier organismo sin importar qué tan
complejo puede hacer
la técnica
viene el nombre gris pero viene de el
acrónimo de las siglas en inglés que
significan grupos de secuencias
repetidas palindromía cortas inter
espaciadas
no importa el título ahora
lo importante es que gracias a los
trabajos de jennifer dude nadie manuel
carpentier sabemos que cris por casa es
un sistema por el cual las bacterias se
defienden de los virus cómo funciona
resulta que cuando un virus que sería el
pósito azul que está allá arriba infecta
a una bacteria le manda su adn algunas
pocas veces esa bacteria logra
reaccionar a la infección y rompe el dna
viral y cuando lo rompe lo inactiva
cuando eso sucede
pues la bacteria logra sobrevivir se
detiene la infección y va a poder dejar
descendencia pero la bacteria hace algo
más coge esos pedacitos del dna roto del
virus y los incorpora en su propio
genoma y no los incorpora en cualquier
parte ella los incorpora en una región
específica donde colecciona esos
pedacitos del virus esa región es
crispar
lo asombroso de esto viene ahora
cuando esa bacteria sobrevive dejará
descendencia y cualquier descendiente
habrá heredado todo el genoma de esa
bacteria por lo tanto todos esos
descendientes tienen en su genoma esos
pedacitos cuando muchas generaciones uno
dos tres cientos de generaciones después
una descendiente vuelve a ser infectada
por un virus idéntico o muy similar
una proteína llamada cas que sería la
bolita verde va a una copia de ese
genoma que había que había guardado de
ese virus de ese pedacito y luego
utilizar como una guía y se va a ir
escaneando por toda la célula por toda
la bacteria a ver dónde lo encuentro y
cuando lo encuentre va a ser un gen
viral obviamente lo va a romper esto le
garantiza esas descendientes una
respuesta y una sobrevivencia muchísimo
muchísimo más alta y mucho más rápida es
decir que cris percas es un sistema
inmunológico pero basado en genes
este sistema se está utilizando ahora
entonces para editar el genoma que
necesitaría yo
una guía que sería como una palabra de
20 letras pequeñita
cas la proteína que se va a asociar con
la guía para ir buscando y después
cortar el adn y además yo puedo poner
una secuencia modelo de reparación que
va a tener el gen in o el cambio que yo
quiero poner
el problema de esta técnica actualmente
para editar genomas tan grandes como los
de un mamífero es que
buscar una palabra de 20 letras
un libro de cocina que está escrito en
solo cuatro letras ats g
y que para el equivalente de los seres
humanos sería de 10 millones de páginas
es extremadamente alto es decir que
cuando usted pone cris por casa así como
está puede terminar editando el genoma
no una ni dos sino tal vez cien o mil
veces porque esa palabra va a estar
muchas veces en ese libro
entonces en la universidad haciendo el
doctorado en yale justamente trabajando
continuó en el departamento de pediatría
para la facultad de medicina
desarrollamos y adaptamos un sistema que
permitía hacer dos cortes le llamamos el
2 nick cage y consistía simplemente
en un caso y condicionarlo para
que cortará solamente cuando encontrara
el otro caso es decir que el hacía dos
cortes al mismo tiempo qué significa eso
que la probabilidad de encontrar dos
palabras y que además una esté cerca de
la otra en ese mismo libro es muchísimo
menor qué significa eso que la técnica
era mucho más específica y mucho más
eficiente
con este sistema logramos desarrollar
animales y líneas de animales
transgénicas y células humanas
transgénicas también aquí se ve la como
ponemos la microinyección y íbamos
cambiando genes que ya habíamos
detectado eran relevantes para
enfermedades como la diabetes y en el
cáncer en las biopsias de los niños
enfermos
esto generaba bueno por un lado
y las líneas de ratones
tenían
teníamos que ponerles dañarles digamos
con este sistema los un gen que fuera
valioso para inducirles la enfermedad lo
que están viendo allí son embriones de
ratón micro inyectados que se ven verdes
porque para saber que el gen estaba
puesto teníamos que poner un marcador
que se llama jeff greene flores en pro
de una proteína que florece las que
están abajo son las una de las líneas
células humanas experimentalmente esto
me generaba una controversia emocional
muy fuerte por un lado estaba muy
motivado a poder salvar o de diseñar
terapias que fueran útiles para los
niños con diabetes y con cáncer
y por el otro lado pues me deprimía
enormemente el trabajo de laboratorio
teniendo que inducir les estas mismas
enfermedades a los ratones
el punto es que todas estas tecnologías
nos están llevando a un mundo en el que
va a ser extremadamente fácil y rápido
curar cualquier enfermedad de carácter
genético es más ya de entrada podríamos
curar más de 6000 enfermedades
monogénicas es decir enfermedades cuyo
defecto o cuyo problema es un solo gen
defectuoso se conocen más de 6000
y
ya que nos remontamos y le vamos a meter
la mano a esto
y ya que le vamos a curar el cáncer a
carlitos
porque no le arreglamos esa mutación que
le vimos en el diagnóstico y que muy
probablemente le va a generar parkinson
alzheimer dentro de 50 años
y ahí al lado también le vimos un gen ay
rarito que muy probablemente le va a
generar una miopía porque teniendo la
tecnología sería prácticamente una
negligencia no hacer esos arreglos
y así mismo entonces por qué no lo
hacemos más apuesto más alto
más inteligente
dónde está la línea entre lo que será
curar y lo que será mejorar cuándo será
el día en el que un individuo mejorado
genéticamente vas a poder discriminarnos
al resto con la justa y válida razón de
ser genéticamente superior
esto nos está abriendo las puertas de un
nuevo mundo un nuevo horizonte
en el qué
tendrá tenemos la evolución en nuestras
manos podemos dirigir esos cambios y una
cosa que he aprendido del ser humano es
que como especie siempre se ha
comportado como un niño curioso inquieto
inocente ignorante que empieza jugando
con las cosas después se lastima y
termina aprendiendo he querido traerles
este debate porque espero
que nuestra conciencia nos ayude a que
como especie aprendamos a aceptar la
naturaleza en nuestro ser
y no creernos mejores o superiores que
los demás seres vivos de este planeta y
para que por favor pensemos antes de
actuar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]